in der nächsten runde müssen unsere
jungs mit einem klaps auf den po erraten
welches hinterteil zu ihrer freundin
gehört und würde sie heute diese sendung
wirft so ein schlechtes licht auf unsere
spezies auf uns als menschen
leute das müsst ihr euch geben ich habe
auf youtube einen club gefunden ein
video das so eins zu eins
höchstwahrscheinlich im fernsehen liebt
und als ich mir dieses video angeschaut
was beide way auch 6,6 millionen aufrufe
hat habe ich mir gedacht was lief schief
und zwar ist es ein video von dem
youtube-kanal taft der zu der
gleichnamigen sendung taff auf prosieben
gehört und die haben eine reihe die das
pärchen check wo die so verschiedene
pärchen einladen und denen dann aufgaben
geben oder die tests machen lassen und
ja diese folge von pärchen check ist
relativ extrem erkennt er seine liebste
an einem tor klappt wie erkennt er sie
ohne sie zu sehen
das lief so im fernsehen leute ziemlich
abstoßend damit ist auch schon der
komplette sinn dieser folge
zusammengefasst denn es geht darum ob
pärchen einander blind erkennen was ist
eigentlich erstmal recht lustige idee
ist aber die umsetzung gehabt dass in
dem fall gemacht hat und wie die
vorgesehen haben dass männer ihre frau
vor sie ihre partnerin erkennen die ist
relativ seltsam werden letztendlich geht
es darum dass man die eigene freundin
durch grabschen erkennen sollen in einem
kölner hallenbad stritten drei paare an
um herauszufinden wer vornehmen sich am
besten kennt als preis winkt ein
gemeinsamer es wellness wochenende
paare eine garderobe und kameras die
alles zeigen also die machen der sohn
der seinen dem es drei pärchen
eingeladen
die jeweils aus einem mann und eine
blondine bestehen und ja der ganze sinn
der sache ist jetzt quasi herauszufinden
ob der mann seine freundin blind erkennt
und nico sind seit sechs jahren zusammen
und kennen sich aus der berufsschule
was ist so besonders an nico heuer das
ist auch gerne müsst euch geben was sie
einander besonders finden egal wir sind
seit sechs jahren zusammen seit sechs
jahren sind die beiden in einer
beziehung die haben sechs jahre zeit
gehabt um sich kennenzulernen und alle
höhe und tiefpunkte der anderen personen
und den kompletten charakter der andere
personen kennenzulernen und was ist das
was bei nina hängen geblieben ist und
was schützt er in seiner nächsten
wieso eine beste freundin ich kann sehr
viel blödsinn mitmachen ich habe gestern
fast alles hier so sollt ihr das
eigentlich aussehen dass sechs jahren
würde ich sagen oder eigentlich hatte
man so sagen sie ja ich mag den
charakter die ist voll lustig ich kann
ja alles anvertrauen oder halt ich mag
seinen bart victoria und jonas sind
partner 2 sie haben sich vor fünf jahren
auf einer party kennengelernt und sofort
ineinander verliebt die
biologiestudentin weiß eine sache an
jonas ganz besonders zu schätzen
okay okay jetzt bin ich gespannt leute
das erste pärchen hat reingeschossen
also zumindest sie hat rein geschissen
das ist jetzt kein nummer zwei mal
schauen ob dies besser machen auch hier
schon wieder leute was was geht da ab
die sind fünf jahre zusammen und was ist
nach fünf jahren beziehung hängen
geblieben
was hat victoria zu bieten
die schöne brüste ok nehmen den in den
linien ganz ehrlich so können wir das
nicht machen leute
heute läuft es wirklich so ab dass man
in beziehungen sondern sechs jahren
irgend ein äußerliches merkmal am besten
findet ein anderer personen
ja ok übels der scheiß charakter aber
eine schöne nase in patrizier und dennis
sind das dritte paar jung und frisch
verliebt aber die 17 jährige weiß schon
warum denn ist der richtige für sie ist
jetzt bin ich gespannt patricia patricia
bitte meine hoffnung in die menschheit
schwindet drastisch kannst du bitte
etwas dagegen unternehmen
[Musik]
okay leute die menschheit ist noch nicht
ganz verloren wir sind schon ziemlich
marsch aber es gibt noch hoffnung sehr
gern meine freundin auf jeden fall unter
tausenden anderen daraus okay jetzt eine
frage wurde er auch gefragt was er an
seine folgen am besten findet und hat
einfach gar nichts gesagt
deswegen jetzt aber direkt zum content
packs kippen wir können zu einer
freundin wirklich dazu gehen unsere
mädels in unserem test kabinen
die jungs müssen durch eine öffnung
greifen und ertasten welche von den
frauen ihre freundin es jetzt hätte mich
es gab noch mal mit voller wucht was
einfach so die idee hinter dieser
sendung ist
dafür gibt es nur ein wort
ok vier worte abstoßend eine blickdichte
brille macht schummeln unmöglich und des
beginns und wie fühlt sich das an
weich und zart aber es war eigentlich
bei jedem meter ich bin wirklich
geschockt gerade auch krass ist die
machen das einfach in einem freibad bei
so komplett normale betrieb im
hintergrund planschen das so dreijährige
und er steht einfach so ein komplettes
kamerateam von prosieben die drei
kabinen dahin stellen in denen männer
ihre freundin ertasten
nachdem er alle drei mädels angetastet
hat besteht seiner entscheidung fest
die tour ist ihm seine freundin wirklich
gut ich habe es gerade eben gesagt leute
gebt euch das da hängen leute wirklich
einfach am beckenrand die sind im wasser
da unten die hängen am beckenrand und
schauen einfach dazu im hintergrund
läuft so ein kind mit seinem vater lang
und mittendrin ist einfach diese touch
kabinen von prosieben
als nächstes ist jonas an der reihe im
gegensatz zu den anderen jungs hatte
eine ganz eigene auslegung infrarot bis
hin zu ertasten wieder beliebt okay da
willst du das wirklich machen nur am
rande hinter dir im pool sind jetzt
gerade wirklich 10 drittklässler die
ganz genau zuschauen und zuhören was du
da machst wirst immer noch ertasten wie
bikini sitzt ob den frauen diese
variante des ertasten gefällt wie auch
immer jonas ist siegesgewiss
kurze frage sollte was ich nicht
verstehe warum dreht man das in einem
öffentlichen hallenbad während der volle
betrieb ist also was hat man davon dass
man das in einem geöffneten hallenbad
macht man hätte es einfach irgendein
studium machen können es geht ja auch
naja ich warte mal leute mir ist gerade
eine sache eingefallen ist nicht eine
von den mädels in dieser sendung
minderjährig doch diese patricia des 17
ja muss los wo das einfach eine 17
jährige die von erwachsenen jungen
männern ja frei für kabine nummer zwei
ist ja auch seine aussage nach das was
er am meisten
sorry das klingt hart das zu sagen ich
hoffe dir noch immer ein anderes gesagt
aber seine aussage nach wie man jetzt
hier gehört ist dass das was er am
meisten an seiner freundin mag
irgendwann komisches gefühl jetzt
wirklich sind aber der fremdfirma ganz
akut zu erste rate ich bin jetzt auch
gerade zum struggle einerseits ist das
halt schon so wie ihr dass es sich lohnt
darüber zu sprechen andererseits es ist
ja einfach selbst also ich würde euch
das nicht unbedingt zeigen aber ich
würde euch zeigen wie ich darüber lustig
machen versteht was ich meine
d ja das ist jetzt gerade wirklich
schmerzhaft das ist hier die 17 jährige
die das gerne so stellt
als nächstes ist nico an der reihe im
gegensatz zu seinem vorgänger erkennt er
seine liebste auch so die nächste runde
wird etwas schwieriger
die jungs müssen den bund ihrer freundin
erkennen wieder da muss man es war doch
klar kommen leute vor fünfeinhalb jahren
wurde dieses video hochgeladen
das heißt wenn ihr vor sechs jahren oder
so teuren fernseher einfach
ausgeschaltet habt hätte es sein können
dass sie einfach diese sendung sehen wie
einfach mitten in einem freibad wo im
hintergrund im pool zehnjährige sich im
wasserball zu schmeißen einfach das hier
abgeht
ich sage mit patricia und dennis in 2
im monat zusammen doch der 18 jährige
scheint seine freundin schon gut zu
kennen diesen seit einem monat zusammen
okay wir sind seit einem monat zusammen
und haben aber so gefühlt so die
normalste beziehung also haben sie die
normalsten positiven dinge dieser
einander bemerkt haben wobei es mal ganz
kurz andere frage leute welches pärchen
hört von dieser sender und hört so dass
prosieben oder taff so eine sendung
drehen will
und denkt sich dann so jonas hatte keine
probleme die oberweite seiner freundin
zu erkennen
doch beim und stößt er an seine grenzen
was wohl victoria dazu sagt und wenn sie
heute diese sendung wird so ein
schlechtes licht auf unsere spezies auf
uns als menschen
er ist wirklich komplett los ja
eigentlich schon
also die seit fünf jahre zusammen und er
erkennt genau einen körperteil von ihr
und wir kommen zum übereinstimmung spiel
hier stellen wir den paaren pikante
fragen und patricia und dennis machen
den anfang
hatten sie schon einmal etwas mit einer
frau ich war dieses standbild sie machen
irgendwo ein neues spiel irgendwie sie
keine ahnung ich habe noch nie und es
sind einfach kläger es sind wirklich so
cannon 30 dreijährige gefühlt im
hintergrund dieses bildes es sind
einfach zu zehnmal so viele leute die
nichts mit dem video zu tun haben im
bild als leute die eigentlichen bild
sein sollten eigentlich beste freundin
warum nicht
wie jonas das wohl findet keine probleme
mit jonas ist es glaube ich eh alles
egal solange eine sache stimmt irgendwie
oder in der nächsten runde müssen unsere
jungs mit einem klaps auf den po erraten
welches hinterteil zu ihrer freundin
gehört also wieso muss man da noch einen
draufsetzen es war wirklich schon
seltsam genug bisher
es muss eigentlich nicht sein dass man
jetzt das doch nicht wir haben gerade
schon gesehen wie junge männer die
freundinnen von anderen jungen männern
die direkt daneben standen abtasten
während diverse dreijährige im
hintergrund spielen das ist auf der
seltsamen skala schon relativ weit oben
aber das hat sich natürlich gedacht das
reicht es noch nicht wir müssen noch
mehr scheiße machen anders ledige oder
wirds ne ganz ehrlich ich glaube an der
stelle bin ich berechtigterweise raus
also sollte real tat das ist einfach
wird die vorstellung dass so was
irgendwie im mittagsprogramm im
fernsehen lief was sagt ihr dazu findet
ihr das normal also ganz offen also ich
habe meine ehrliche meinung die
kommentare was wir nicht davon
beeinflussen was ich gesagt habe wie
findet ihr das von ihr so was im
fernsehen sehen würdet was würdet ihr
euch denken dass man die kommentare und
checkt hier drüben einen für euch
vorgeschlagen das video aus das mal von
mir leute ich für eure augen heute
macht's gut